la fierté de la France quel que soit nos
opinions politiques qu'on soutien nous
pas le gouvernement du président c'est
pas le sujet tout ce qui est promis est
réellement livré et tout ce qui est
livré a été promis tout ce qui est livré
aussi fonctionne je mettrai pas une
pierre dans le jardin d' de nos alliés
mais c'est notre honneur aussi que
d'avoir effectivement livrer des
dispositifs qui sont
fiables les vies humaines sont une
priorité constante pour nous et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous nous
réunissons encore et encore la raison
pour laquelle nous construisons nos
coalitions la raison pour la nous
augmentons nos capacités parce que cette
guerre nous concerne
tous le renforcement des capacités
d'artillerie et l'un de nos principaux
besoins pour gagner cette guerre il est
essentiel que nous investissions nos
ressources dans la production de plus
grandes quantités de munition
d'artiriie rrouve notre correspondant en
Ukraine Guliver Gul vous êtes àamor
aujourd'hui qus sont d'abord vos toutes
premières informations sur le
terrain alors aujourd'hui nous nous
avons été pas très loin de bakmou et
parler avec le vice-commandant de l'un
des bataillons Ukrainiens engagés dans
la défense de ces terr-l il convient de
parler de défense parce que sur toute la
ligne de front à l'Est ce sont les
Russes qui ont l'initiative mais pour le
moment les Ukrainiens ne subissent pas
de perte territorial majur ce commandant
nous a parlé d'une tentative d'attaque
il y a 2 jours avec un grand nombre de
chars engagés par la Russie I et il nous
a dit que la grande majorité de ces
chars ont été tout simplement détruits
et cette nouveau tentative des Russes
d'avancer à côté de bakmou a été
repoussé il nous a aussi fait remarquer
que on parlait de l'idée que les Russes
pourraient attaquer la ville de
tassiviar qui est un peu la la prochaine
ville à l'ouest de bakmou s'il voulaient
avancer dans la direction ouest il y a
quelques mois cela semblait comme une
vraie possibilité que une offensive
russe sur tassiviar pourrait devenir une
réalité pour le moment chassivar reste
absolument aux mains des Ukrainiens même
si bien sûr une grande partie de cette
petite ville est très sévèrement
endommagée mais on ne parle pas du tout
de combat à tassiviar les combats sur
cette partie de la ligne de front sont
toujours vraiment aux alentours de la
ville de bakmou et même dans la banlieu
de bakmou donc pour ce vice-commandant
cela c'était en quelque sorte un succès
pour les Ukrainiens mais les officiers
lui et un autre aussi à qui j'ai demandé
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez
confiance que l'Ukraine peut continuer
eu subir ces pressions russes et à pas
perdre ces ces villes clés comme
chassiviar ou encore avdka ou koupiansk
d'autres villes qui sont dans le
collimateur des Russes ils ont voulu
afficher une confiance mais ils ont dit
tout de même tout dépend de nos alliés
et des fournitures de armes et de
financement pour que l'Ukraine puisse
continuer euh cette cette lutte contre
la Russie justement Guliver quelles sont
les réactions en Ukraine après les
annonces de la
France alors je pense que les mots de du
ministre de la Défense monsieur le Cornu
sont c'est de la musique aux oreilles en
quelque sorte pour les Ukrainiens
72 char de type César qui fonctionne
très bien ils ont une très bonne
réputation ici le ministre n'a pas dit
faux sur ce point là que ce que la
France a fourni tout fonctionne tout est
de bonne qualité même si la France a
fourni moins en terme de quantité que
d'autres pays et là la quantité annoncée
est assez élevée 72 mais même si
Monsieur le Cornu a dit que tout ce que
la France a promis jusqu iici a été
livré là pour les 72 si je comprends
bien il n'y a que 18 dont le financement
est assuré une partie par l'Ukraine et
une partie par la France il reste une
soixantaine euh qui on ne sait pas
encore qui va payer la France appelle à
ses partenaires européens de payer pour
l'achat de ce matériel on va voir si
elle arrive à les convaincre les
Ukrainiens sont bien conscients qu'il y
a eu des promesses non tenues par ces
partenaires européens notamment cette
promesse de fournir à l'Ukraine 1
million d'obus jusqu'ici seulement
300000 ont été fabriqués et envoyés ou
sont en route pour l'Ukraine merci
Guliver Guliver craque donc
correspondant en Ukraine